I've definitely never dyed my hair
before to be honest it kind of scares me
guys my culture don't usually dye their
hair I think that's exactly it
being a guy that goes with a little bit
of a stigma but what I'm most nervous
about is how I'm gonna feel after I have
it on when I see somebody change your
hair color that person had balls it's
been a little difficult to get men to
change their hair a lot of guys like
regiments usually I'm like more the
boring one of the group I'm not the
person to do something this drastic it's
the quickest way to change yourself I'm
excited it's really gonna give me some
more confidence something that I'm I
lack a little bit of especially Gen X Y
now men are actually choosing their own
hair style I think social media has a
big impact I saw some guys with cool
hair and I'm like hey I could probably
do that when they really rock it out
they start to see things change in their
lives I'm most looking forward to see
myself in the mirror and it not be what
I've been seeing for the past 20 so
years each one of them have extreme
different looks that they've chosen for
themselves I'm excited to take them to
their elevated look I'm gonna go darker
with men I don't necessarily see them go
dark that often and the only reason why
they're going dark is because it's
emotional because I'm blonde people
sometimes look at me and they have a
preconceived notion of what my
personalities like I kind of have to
work to have people take me serious
sometimes when you are looking at
somebody with dark hair with light eyes
it's mesmerizing I think something that
can happen in the course of a single day
and it doesn't take discipline in time
to see the result I think it's really
gonna help from light to dark you're
putting on a single color but when
you're going blonder it's completely a
different process I want to go blonde
today because I know that's a call I
could rock when you're going to that
platinum blonde you're gonna have a lot
of fun I come from a Haitian background
that is totally unacceptable it's
supposed to be very professional at all
times so my mom would probably cut my
head off when a man's walking down the
street dark skin light hair there are a
lot of people that are looking because
were like dang he exudes confidence I
can't wait to take some pictures with it
naughty pictures one guy in the group of
guys has changed our hair color it
starts to become infectious I seen a lot
of guys with purple hair lately and
I think it looks pretty bad as there
used to be this your blonde or your
brown but now with men being able to
look outside the box in this recent
explosion of rainbow s care guys are
like screw it I'm creative purple is one
of my favorite colors purple loves me
and I think purple looks good on me I
feel with this wide range of color it's
definitely taking our next generation to
another level since I'm gonna do it I
might as well just go babe people are
exercising their creative space and with
hair I really want to try silver hair
I've always wanted to look like a video
game character the acceptance of gray
hair its boosting confidence because now
they're not explaining why they're
prematurely gray they're just like oh
it's really an I'm most nervous about
man
there's so many things what people will
say limp a ski Meijin guy walking around
with white hair from darkest agen hair
color and it's coarse and there's a lot
of dimension to it you're lightening
your discoloring you're seeing where
this hairs going you're pretty much
gonna have to plan your whole day around
it and I've seen so many times that I've
spun the chair around and they get a
shot of themselves in the mirror and
it's like whoa three two one
Wow doesn't look great
who is that that's crazy hello well this
is just a really really great color for
you so a lot of people are gonna think
wait is that your natural hair I love it
who do you think is gonna react the best
here right now um I don't know maybe
myself what do you think just like crazy
my hair is like another color I'm
getting used to it I really like it do
you still feel boring I definitely do
not feel bored what am i L what what oh
my god I like a pony it's like a hint of
silver yeah with some lilac in it I'm
excited I think it matches my
personality
Oh whoo
holy moly who this is
hazel hair I honestly think you look
like the best version of yourself whoo
yo girls that color your hair mad
respect because beauty is seriously pain
before obviously it's like a regular guy
but like now there's like BAM on your
face if you want to change your hair
color do it just do it it's about time
we change the standards I would consider
coming my hair again I look forward to
moving forward in my life with this new
look